[ __ ] that maniacal laugh dude
[Music]
it is time to talk about our boy Elon
again
I like it Steve Green's costume and
Twitter yes Steve greens that's a good
one I didn't get it deleted something
[ __ ] Twitter yeah
um Twitter so we all know that this guy
recently just acquired Twitter it's been
a long-standing year-long the whole
thing but some crazy changes have been
made in literally the recent weeks and
stuff what has everybody heard Twitter
has been so fun like ever since the
Takeover I've been on it every day like
before this I was just going on there
for like crypto and stocks true but now
it's [ __ ] so funny just seeing how he
like facts checks the White House check
out like all this I'm just like what the
[ __ ] is what a g bro they just uh
actually it just fact checked the White
House to the point where the White House
deleted a recent tweet yeah and
obviously that's good that's even
funnier it's bite in a bunch too yeah
fast checks bite is not making those
tweets bro I know there's you don't even
know how to work Apple shakes when he
touches his phone man he's like my
grandpa I saw the exchange with him and
Stephen King about uh wanting to charge
people for blue checks and he was like
20 bucks a month it's eight dollars
actually so and then Stephen King was
like 20 get the [ __ ] out of here I'm out
of here I'm not gonna pay 20 for this
and then Elon was saying like oh well we
gotta we can't make sure we can't make
Twitter only rely on advertisements like
what about eight dollars a month anyone
can get verified by just paying the
thing or if you still have to be
verified the usual way and then you pay
eight bucks I was gonna say everyone
just just gonna I'm actually for it
because I'm like if you have a blue
check mark chances are you're using it
for your business yeah that makes sense
you're just I mean you pay for whatever
like right off johnsmith.com anyways
even if you go through GoDaddy you gotta
[ __ ] pay right
or whatever the hottest site on the deck
right so I'm like if you're gonna use
Twitter for your business platform to
get a blue check mark which is why you
have a blue check mark then you might as
well pay for it I don't know why they're
complaining about eight bucks because I
just spent more than that on this
beautiful meal
worth it it's the idea that people don't
like paying for something they were
already getting free yeah dude didn't
you say like you're still getting to use
Twitter for free yeah
you could be a regular user not have a
blue checkbook but then they'll read
everything but but then the eight
dollars even with the blue check mark
now you get like more or something like
there's something to it like if you have
a blue check mark you could still use it
for free it's not like you can't you
know but then now you get to hold the
blue check mark will cost users eight
dollars a month uh just to hold blue
checklist to retain the verification
otherwise you're just a regular user
yeah I think that's dope if you don't
pay it it gets taken away yeah yeah so
then if you don't want your car get it
taken away yeah
I like that different colors if you
didn't pay you get a red check what
would the red check mark be yeah you
will for for the Eight dollar monthly
charge users users will also get
priority and replies mentions and search
ability to post longer videos and audio
half as many ads you know what I mean so
it's half as many yeah there there is a
value proposition for people that are
still a king mad bro Jesus Christ that's
it that's why it's writing little scary
ass stories yeah yeah his life sucks
his life sucks that's why I'm trying to
scare Kids all the Time JK needs a good
rivalry you're my friend God damn it um
but yeah he said with the new strategy
it'll give Twitter a revenue stream to
reward content creators yeah see so
you're gonna get that so you're gonna
make your money back it's eight bucks
that's [ __ ] cool well I don't know I
pay for YouTube Red I'm one of the few
people that actually pay for it like a
dumbass but do you like it when it was
YouTube I think it's YouTube something
stupid yeah but no ads is probably yeah
it's no ads the videos keep playing like
when you close the app like I don't know
there's other things that you get I
forget what regular YouTube was because
I don't have it no you don't know that
life no more yeah we have Premium Too
YouTube premium is tight though and you
can watch [ __ ] Cobra Kai just being
able to watch all your videos and not
have like two ads play especially when
you go to YouTube it's because you're
trying to just receive content right
away too but when you don't have [ __ ]
really long ads in between every video
because you want a video hot but every
video hop is another like room for like
that's why I can't like watch like Hulu
shows sometimes because no matter right
when it gets juicy it's like boom
regular commercial life back like in the
90s but right now if you get Spectrum
you got [ __ ] ads anyways yeah I don't
use Spectrum well what how much does
YouTube Premium cost I forget I don't
know probably the same [ __ ] like 15 a
month I don't [ __ ] it's a lot yeah
hey if you guys forgot it must not be
that much I think when you're a Creator
it it it way it works like it makes
sense to having it or just the idea of
being able to continue playing that
video while you're using other apps on
your phone it's like only YouTube
premium can do that and you couldn't do
it before and it's like wait a minute
that's a [ __ ] small but useful daily
yeah it is yeah you know that's true to
saving or downloading videos if you
don't have service or whatever the [ __ ]
so or just use an ad blocker just go
ahead and use an ad blocker you got an
ad blocker how does that work I need to
find one yeah how does that work dude
bloggers don't play the ads on your on
your yeah is it a software
yeah it just ties to your uh browser
what would you say if you had to pay a
monthly fee to keep your belt black
or else it goes back a color well I'm
not even a black belt
joke's on you dude that'd be hilarious
that's like a McDonald's like they help
you progress to Black Belt but to
maintain it yeah you have to also pay a
subscription or else it goes down down
down dude that's a model that's for sure
a business model for a lot of Jesus
schools I knew one guy who was kind of
like scary and he was like a big [ __ ]
masculine dude and he's he started
crying because he didn't get his his
brown belt as soon as I heard about this
I was like you are such a [ __ ] he cried
because he didn't get his brown belt he
should have been demoted for not being
martial art enough that's what I'm
saying and he like he he was supposed to
win a tournament and if he didn't if he
won the tournament he was going to get
promoted and he didn't get it so he
started crying about it and he was like
complaining to the the professor oh God
and he promoted himself why do you do
that wait what he came in with his own
belt and as soon as I found out about
that I lost all my respect for him wait
I was like dude you're a grown man I was
like did his own ceremony he did his own
ceremony not even a ceremony he just
came in and was like yeah he got the
belt off Amazon but doesn't your coach
go like yo I never gave that to you yeah
and that was interesting and then what
did he say
what he's a grown ass man I guess I'm a
brown belt you technically can stop him
right can't you just get in there and be
like hey if you don't beat me right now
if he wants to get beat up and he can
get beat up it's not on him it doesn't
matter what belt you are yeah you have
to get beat up yeah yeah it's not on us
if you want to live your if you want to
live your life like that go ahead I'm a
flash belt see
please explain it's just my belly yeah
yeah what belt are you I don't flash
about I don't wear belts you should add
belts to dancing that'd be tight not for
who you battle oh dude you'd have the
wackest people with the blackest belts
really and so many concepts with the
belts it's the same thing with like
dance studios you get a lot of people
that go I've been dancing for 15 years
but it still sucks and they look at it
like time based yeah it's like bro I
wouldn't [ __ ] brag about that because
it doesn't mean you're good that's the
funniest thing it's like when people be
like I've been doing this for a lifetime
and I'm like and that's all you learn
yeah
some people are in the studio for so
[ __ ] long that they just equate that
to being like proficient and it's like
yeah that's not how it works yeah
elitists yeah that shit's really funny
though I've been a dancer for 50 years
and I'm like and that's all you know how
to do like damn you sh I'm so surprised
I thought you would have been better by
now you better know how to tap dance and
Bongo I know it's one of those things
like you learn so slow why you learn so
slow this one went to Bhangra you better
know the whole Spectrum you better it's
definitely one of those things where if
you're talking precedes your action then
you're just whack you already know yeah
there's a lot of people like that if
there's yeah exactly if there's no rep
that's like unspoken then and you have
to tell people how good you are what the
[ __ ] is this that's one of my favorite
things to do is um is like when people
do stuff like that I'm like really
that's so [ __ ] cool tell me more you
do that to me I like to [ __ ] gas them
up dude yeah I'm sitting right here man
and then you gas them up and you just
wait for that that's nice [ __ ] moment
that nice moment and then you so oh
really you've been doing that for that
long
wow I'm so surprised you don't know more
[ __ ] that maniacal laugh dude I was
talking to a
cinematographer the other day
he was saying that that same thing
happens with like guys who call
themselves photographers and then you go
to their page and it's just naked chicks
they shoot but yeah they just shoot like
girl hey protect those guys we need more
of them
if those pictures are good though
have you seen that one Russian meme like
he's a photographer and he's like taking
photos of this girl but he's also in his
underwear
that's pretty [ __ ] funny he's liking
his Speedos and he's taking a picture
for her it's like the photographer
doesn't need to be in it too
for the BTS guy I'm trying to think so
we obviously know there's a lot of male
photographers that shoot women females
but I can't think right now of like a
female photographer that only shoots
like male models do you guys know I've
never even heard of that Bart's done
some nudes well who is the camera person
she was a female
there it is she just Shoots for the
magazine so it's whatever oh okay but
it's not like a specialized yeah but
wasn't it Men's Health yeah I was from a
lot mostly man that's mostly man I think
it's because girls film girls and guys
film girls and nobody really wants to
film guys unless gay guys yeah that's
true like when you see those pages of
all dudes it's usually four other dudes
yeah like who takes who's the
photographer for Playgirl yeah I feel
like men buy more men stuff than women
do like I mean what I mean by that is
like like if there was a cam guy right
right most of his customers are gonna be
men not women yes the top cam guys are
are gay right content yeah yeah because
like
females probably can get whatever for
free so it's like they don't want to
[ __ ] buy and also women women don't
want to watch men they want to watch
other women mad at other women
as stats have shown as stats yeah the
numbers are there
[Music]
foreign
[Music]